so how are you good morning everybody
and welcome back
so I'm Lee Woodley I work at triple a s
and I'm really interested in both the
technical so I think online tools and
the human so I think people community
managers who really make scientific
collaborations scientific teamwork
scientific communities actually function
productively so I've been invited to
talk here this morning about communities
of practice and as Jeff is outlined
that's really because what we want to do
now for the remainder of the conference
is think about what comes next
you know we've had these productive
useful generative conversations but what
now and the notion of a community of
practice is something that has been
kicked around for at least a couple of
years but we've never really had
explicit conversations about what does
that mean what does that look like how
might we actually create that and
participate in it so what I'm going to
do is I'm essentially going to give you
a ten-minute primer on communities of
practice theory so the notion here isn't
to be top-down so about saying you know
there's a right way and a way that we
can do this
it's to give us a framework it's to get
us back to the theory so that we're
thinking about this from the same
perspective and we can use that then as
a way of opening up the dialogue about
what things we might want to use and
where we may decide to go forward from
here and listening to this and going
actually we're not community perhaps at
all is a completely valid response so
there's no assumptions about the the
output here so I'm going to be doing is
drawing on the communities of practice
literature primarily this is the work of
Etienne Wenger and colleagues so they've
been thinking a lot about knowledge
generation and social learning over the
years that have come up with a lot of
the foundational ideas about communities
of practice and this talk is going to
break out into three key takeaways and
those takeaways are designed to match
along with the core themes of the
conference so we have models methods and
measures so I'm gonna start first of all
talking about methods so that's the why
why why do we need communities of
practice ever
how do we deal with knowledge generation
how do we deal with the cultivation and
the the use of knowledge then I'm going
to move on and I'm going to outline the
model for communities of practice so
communities of practice have a strict
definition we think about them in a
particular way so I'm gonna elucidate
that model and drop in a few questions
that might help us stop thinking about
what that might apply to to us in this
sites Outreach space and then finally
the final thing is measures so really
getting to evaluation and just touching
on this idea of well okay if we do go
down this route and we do decide that we
want to do something more together how
are we gonna know whether it's working
or not okay so let's start at the
beginning so let's start with the
methods and thinking about knowledge
management so if you think about how
generative hopefully the the past couple
of days have been for you and you think
about the the conversations that we've
had as a result of the lining talks
around the tables in the corridors that
story Collider out on the terrace over
lunch and you think about what you gain
from that really we've been iterating
knowledge together we've been dropping
in our own experiences the things that
we've done sharing those with others and
and building on that together and that
really fits in with the five ways in
which we think about knowledge so first
of all knowledge can't be codified
simply as a static object so if we'd
given you all a bit of paper or a laptop
and we said right on everything you know
about science outreach that wouldn't
really be very useful and if we'd put
that all together in one place that
isn't gonna make any one of us any
better at doing science outreach so we
think about knowledge is not being able
to be broken down into that single
static thing part of the reason for that
is that knowledge as I'm sure you're
well aware can be both explicit so the
kind of things that we choose to codify
in publications in posters in
presentations and implicit so the kind
of things that we learn through
interacting with each other through
having conversations through talking
about how things are done around here
as a result knowledge is therefore also
iterative so like the pros
of science itself you know we we may
start with a core set of assumptions of
core set of things that we know but
we're always building on those we're
always testing them adding on a bit from
some videos trying that out coming up
with new knowledge and that means that
knowledge the generation of knowledge is
a social endeavor you know we don't sit
in our dreaded silos and learn stuff by
ourselves we learn it through
interacting with each other and then
finally for knowledge to be maximally
useful we talk about how important it is
for knowledge to get out of those silos
and actually cross boundaries into other
areas so knowledge is maximally useful
when we can reuse it and apply it to
different situations and so the reason
that I'm outlining all of this is that
communities of practice this notion of
them it's as arisen as a way of
cultivating and managing knowledge
together so Hume you to practice comes
together around doing and managing
knowledge in these ways that I've just
described so to end the first section
some questions so do we think we need a
community of practice in terms of
bubbling up the various expertise that
we have in this room and beyond the room
for the folks that weren't able to be
here does a community of practice sound
like a framework that might be helpful
and then reflecting on your own needs
and your own expertise you know what
knowledge do you have to give and in in
what format how have you most enjoyed
sharing things here you know maybe you
ended up in conversations about things
that you didn't realize you were going
to talk about and these are things that
you want to take forward and then what
would you like to get in terms of
gaining knowledge from other people do
you know what you don't know and do you
know how you might go about finding it
out okay so the second section as I say
we're going to talk about models so I
specifically want to outline what we
mean when we talk about a community of
practice and so venue and colleagues
describe a community of practice as
having three key structural elements so
they talked about the notion of a domain
a community and a practice so the domain
this is really what it is we are focused
on so for a community of practice to be
most effective we need to know
why is that we gather we miss what he
gets at the the purpose the goals of why
we're coming together as a community and
Mallon gives us an identifier identity
so we should self-identify as being part
of a community of practice and that
allows us to know why it is that we are
here that also allows people looking in
from the outside so other stakeholders
who may be interested in what we're
doing
to see that there's legitimacy in that
so we we've created a definition of why
we're doing what we're doing and so one
of the questions that I would ask about
this is is science outreach our domain
or is that too big is that is that too
amorphous is there too much going on
there are we actually talking about
multiple sub communities of practice
focused on different areas different
types of outreach different audiences
for outreach I don't want to presuppose
what that looks like but if we use this
framework to think about this how might
that influence what we we might want to
create after this meeting so a second
structural element of a community of
practice is the community so we've
talked a lot over the last couple of
days about reaching out to underserved
audiences making sure that we're
including all voices in the room making
sure that we don't make assumptions but
that we listen deeply and therefore we
learn from from everybody that we bring
together so once we've identified a
particular domain or various subdomains
then we need to be quite intentional
about saying well who do we need there
around that table to help us advance our
knowledge to cultivate our activities in
that particular domain and then the
final piece as I hope is following on
quite logically is the practice so
that's okay we know one domain is we
know who we've got around the table what
are we actually gonna do together just
standing up an online site and putting a
bunch of documents in there that's not a
practice you know we talked about
cultivation of knowledge through the
ways I described at the beginning
through interactions through building
something through trying to tackle a
particular problem you know do we want
to work on it so we working on
evaluation models and comparing what
we've each done in our different
projects
do we want perhaps to you know think
about writing something together you
know then
needs to be an activity or a set of
activities which may include meetings
may include annual conferences may
include webinars may include live chats
but we need to be regularly doing
something together to cultivate this
core knowledge base that we have okay
so now is section 2 so that's thinking
about three structural elements of what
a co P is and then I promise the final
thing that I was going to end with was
touching on the the measures theme or
thinking about the evaluation and so one
of the signs of a healthy community as
it gets set up and as it gets to
maturity is that we were able to be
self-reflective
we're able to kind of say well is this
working for me why am i here are we are
we really doing things that are useful
and with a community of practice then
firstly obviously we need to identify
the shared goals for a community of
practice but it's not just about saying
well are we producing the output the the
report the conversations the thing that
we said we were going to do so it's not
just about saying you know let's let's
count clicks let's count comments let's
count you know what's going on there
because we think about knowledge as I
said is spreading out beyond silos so if
we come together like at a conference
like this and we share knowledge what
happens to that knowledge afterwards so
what are you going to do with what you
learnt here how is that knowledge that
that is being created within a potential
community of practice helping you get
better at your day job or helping you
tell somebody at your Institute how they
could go and look something up or talk
to this other person and learn this
thing we call now the concept of a
double-knit knowledge organization so
that you're in the community of practice
and we're cultivating knowledge together
but then we take it out beyond the
community of practice and we weave it
into what we actually do in the outside
world and that creates really
interesting self-reflection and
evaluation questions because we don't
just measure what goes on in the
community of practice in the group but
we start thinking about what that looks
like out in the world okay so that's the
end of the primer that was cute as a
practice 101 so what I encourage us to
do and Ben's gonna help us think about
it's like ground this now in practical
reality and
what this actually looks like but just
think about you know as a result the
conversations that you've had here what
might this communities of practice
notion mean to you were we thinking
about sub projects is something has
something occurred to you you really
love to work on and that you'd love to
cultivate together with other people so
thank you for listening
I was just wondering um like how do we
build a community without making it
without make putting up extra barriers
like when people see oh it's already a
community like I can't join yeah and I
think there's a there's definitely a
balance to be struck here so we need to
create a strong enough sense of identity
that we I guess a we self-identify as
being part of something we feel
committed to it we want to keep coming
back we want to work together but we
also need to think about you know having
a certain humility that maybe as we
start working on these things we realize
we don't have all the voices around the
table yet and that we actually need to
have pathways through which people can
come and join so these are not intended
to be static entities so for example me
giving example at triple-a yes we have a
social media working group meets Monday
morning 11:00 a.m. and that transects
across all the dreaded silos so it's
various editors various program
directors and so on all of whom don't
have enough time on their own to keep up
with all the changes in social media so
they join this working group once a week
want to share current campaigns things
that are going on so that everybody else
in the organization who's online knows
about it but to to talk about the
changes oh Twitter's made yet another
tweet oh well Instagram now lets you do
this and so by coming together in that
group they learn about that thing in a
quick way once a week that's their
community of practice but the point to
your question then is that's a flexible
domain right people are going to leave
and move on and do other jobs new people
are going to join the organization it's
totally fine that those new hires then
come and integrate into that community
of practice you know it should be
visible enough that people know where
the front door is and then welcoming
enough that if you have a you know a
reason to be there and something that
you want to contribute that you're able
to come in and integrate with those
activities
uh hi Lu I'm Kyle from girl science and
academic stand up I wanted to touch on
something and I kind of want to bring it
out to the room that you mentioned and
it's the reflective practice and I feel
like I don't actually know how often
people do it in their activities and and
it's different from debriefs it's
completely different from D for use and
sharing in in meetings and team meetings
and I'm kind of curious like for you who
straddled the worlds of both UK signs
outreach and the u.s. science outreach
how have you seen it and then maybe in
the discussions that be great to talk
about that yeah I mean I think it's so
it was nice about about this meeting at
least for me from from the perspective
that I'm viewing it from is that we've
intentionally baked in those moments of
reflection here in the fellowship
program that I run we do a week-long
training week in January and we cram
their brains full of all the theory
about communities but every afternoon we
take an hour and a half to just let
people think and we create a basic
worksheet of prompt questions that
they're free to use to help or
completely ignore and discard but it's
like think about how their stuff applies
to you and think about how what we are
doing together as a group is either
helping or hindering or revealing to you
things that you hadn't thought about
before maybe even in the way in which
you interact or or try and work with
this information so I really think
baking in reflection like it's like
coming together and talking about all
those different experiences it is just a
way of giving us that pause to sort of
inhale exhale and then reengage I mean
again it's it's a structural thing in
terms of how we create it it may be I've
seen it done in various different ways
I've seen some communities have a Monday
work outloud session for example is
totally open ended it's online if you
want you can come in there and use it as
an accountability thing as an open
reflection thing where you say this is
what I'm worried about working on or
doing this week
that's a a simple structural we're doing
reflection the way we do with our
worksheets are fellows week that's more
structured and more
elongated because we specifically want
them to figure out how to apply the the
learnings back in their home
organizations we could do this on a
larger scale by coming together once a
year and having reflection baked into
what we are doing as part of that
meeting so it looks like different
things in different places still
rabbinic UT Southwestern and I apologize
if this question is overly naive what is
the relationship between a potential
group like this with the already
existing group of Nabi and I'm not
trying to be hard about it it just is it
useful to have something completely
separate or is it useful to actually
integrate more strongly or have a SUP
working group yeah and I think I think
there's a completely valid questions and
I would say that Nabi is not the only
organization that is thinking about
communities of practice in this space
right there are there are multiple ones
triple-a s convenes one as well I think
part of this is being quite realistic
about what it is that we as individuals
want to achieve right that we we are all
very busy people we cannot be fully
present in multiple different places at
the same time so it's really about
finding finding your tribe finding your
people to do the thing that you want to
work on and I personally don't
necessarily think that it matters who
the convening organization is and I
don't necessarily think those convenien
ization x' have to be in competition
with each other and I'm sure they
wouldn't describe themselves as such so
I think they can be interrelated but we
should also be realistic about not
expecting people to be as engaged in
every location although have visibility
on what is going on in the different
spaces
[Applause]
you